- What I want to do in
this video is think about
the different ways to
represent a molecule.
So the most obvious way is its name.
So, for example, you could be referring to
a molecule of benzene.
Benzene.
But just the word "benzene"
tells you very little
about what actually
makes up this molecule.
And there's other naming
conventions that do
give more information, but you might say,
well, I actually want to know more about
the actual particular
elements that make it up.
Well, that might be, in that case,
it might be useful to move
up to the empirical formula.
Empirical, empirical.
Empirical.
Empirical formula.
And you might be thinking, what does
empirical mean?
In general, the word "empirical"
is referring to something
that comes from observation
or comes through experiments.
If you could say hey, you
know, I from empirical evidence
I now believe this, this
means that you saw data.
This means that you have
some observations that
make you think this new thing.
The reason why we call what
I'm about to write down
the empirical formula, is
because early chemists,
they can't look, they
weren't able to look at
just one molecule, but
they could at least come up
with, they could observe
the ratios of the different
elements that they had in a molecule.
So an empirical formula gives you a ratio
of the elements in the molecule.
So an empirical formula for benzene is ...
It is ...
One carbon for
every, for every hydrogen.
Now you might say, OK, that's nice,
I now know that if I'm
dealing with benzene
I have one carbon for every hydrogen
or one hydrogen for every carbon,
but what does, how many of
each of these do you actually
have in a benzene molecule?
To answer that question,
that's when you would want
to go to the molecular formula.
Molecular.
Molecular formula.
And the molecular formula
for benzene, which is
now going to give us more information than
the empirical formula,
tells us that each benzene
molecule has six hydrogens, and,
sorry, six carbons and six,
(laughs) I'm really having trouble today,
six hydrogens, (laughs) six carbons, and,
six hydrogens.
Now, the ratio is still
one to one, you get that
right over here, it's very easy to go from
a molecular formula to
an empirical formula.
You essentially are losing information.
You're just saying the ratio, OK, look,
it's a ratio of six to six,
which is the same thing as one to one.
If we wanted to, we
could write this as C one
H one just like that to
show us that the ratio
for every carbon we have a hydrogen.
And we see that that's actually
the case in one molecule,
for every six carbons
you have six hydrogens,
which is still a one to one ratio.
That may not satisfy you, you might say,
well, OK, but how are these six carbons
and six hydrogens actually structured?
I want more information.
And for that, you would wanna go to
a structural formula.
Structural formula,
which will actually
give you the structure,
or start to give you the
structure of a benzene molecule.
A benzene molecule would be drawn like...
So you would have six
carbons in a hexagon.
So one, going to write this way, one, two,
three, four, five, six
carbons in a hexagon just like that.
And then you have a
double bond, every other
of these bonds on the
hexagon is a double bond.
Each of these carbons are
also attached to a hydrogen,
also bonded to a hydrogen.
Each of these lines that I'm drawing,
this is a bond, it's a covalent bond,
we go into much more depth
in other videos on that,
but it's a sharing of
electrons, and that's what keeps
these carbons near each
other and what keeps
the hydrogens kind of tied to each, or,
the hydrogens tied to the
carbons and the carbons
tied to the hydrogens.
So let me draw it just like this.
And this is only one
variant of a structural,
it's hard to see this one I just drew,
so let me see if I can do a little bit...
Oh, that's about as good,
hopefully you see there's
a hydrogen there, and there's
a hydrogen right over there.
This is one variant of
a structural formula,
some structural formulas
will actually give you
some 3D information, will
tell you whether a molecule
is kind of popping in or out of the page.
Others might not be as explicit,
once you go into organic chemistry
chains of carbons are just
done, they're just ...
You might see something
like this for benzene,
where the carbons are implicit
as the vertex of each,
there's an implicit carbon
at each of these vertices,
and then you say, OK, carbon's gotta have,
not gotta, but it's
typically going to have
four bonds in its stable state,
I only see one, two, three.
Well, if it's not drawn,
then it must be a hydrogen.
That's actually the convention that people
use in organic chemistry.
So there's multiple ways
to do a structural formula,
but this is a very typical
one right over here.
As you see, I'm just getting more and more
and more information
as I go from empirical
to molecular to structural formula.
Now, I want to make clear, that empirical
formulas and molecular formulas
aren't always different
if the ratios are actually, also show the
actual number of each of those elements
that you have in a molecule.
A good example of that would be water.
Let me do water.
Let me do this in a
different color that I,
well, I've pretty much
already used every color.
Water.
So water we all know,
for every two hydrogens,
for every two hydrogens, and since I
already decided to use
blue for hydrogen let me
use blue again for hydrogen,
for every two hydrogens
you have an oxygen.
You have an oxygen.
It just so happens to be,
what I just wrote down
I kind of thought of in
terms of empirical formula,
in terms of ratios, but
that's actually the case.
A molecule of hydrogen,
sorry, a molecule of water
has exactly two hydrogens and,
and one oxygen.
If you want to see the structural formula,
you're probably familiar with it or you
might be familiar with it.
Each of those oxygens in a water molecule
are bonded to two hydrogens,
are bonded to two hydrogens.
So hopefully this at least begins to
appreciate different ways of referring to
or representing a molecule.